Asians and Koreans in general good great
hygiene especially Koreans I think they
got the face care everything but I would
say the only thing would be the garlic
breath it just hits you man I mean I do
it too but then other than that
[Music]
pristine and welcome back everybody to
another amazing and special episode of
the careful boys and today we are super
honored to have Mr junle in the build
let's go baby let's go I just realized
that round with June B free marketing
June don't even bring it and junri
karate junri
karate anything else what's another
wrong but his is Jun Lee Jun Lee let's
just talk about Jun Le what about pun C
is that a rapper that's not a thing yeah
I
know so hey June what's up man that was
dude you asked that question we were we
were riffing and we gave you space
that's how it is here you know we to do
the best you could we gave you an open
mic he still hasn't said anything get
that mic away from him so what's up June
I'm going to sign this whole thing yeah
I'm great thank you for having me okay
we're going to get rid of the uh very
basic Small Talk questions where are you
from oh oh we're getting okay I'm from I
was born in Guam what did you believe
that I know that about we knew that food
you want to try you didn't know that
chamaro food see you said Guamanian food
I knew it's chamaro food my
ex-girlfriend uh she's is Korean with
stinky ears and she told me that Guam is
like the Hawaii of Korea like a lot of
people like to go there is that how you
were born there it's the it's the
underrated Hawaii yeah yeah you're the
third person I know from Guam wow nice
usually that's like the fun fact that I
grew up with that you're the only person
on the Guam yeah gu guy how did you how
did your family end up there we had
relatives there and my parents just
moved there for a little bit um had me
and then my Mom hated it so what she
took us to America what's wrong with
Guam yeah what is it like is it like
Hawaii or it's just it's a it's a dot
dot huh you can drive around the whole
island in 7 hours which is sizable
that's is it bigger than Wahu then I
don't cuz it don't take 7 hours to go
across hour walk yeah that's true huh
but is it because of the speed limit the
speed limit is like 25 milph oh
yeah dang but then I grew I I went to
Georgia when I was four and then I've
been there like my whole life oh so
you're more like a country Georgian boy
yeah oh you're not like a Guamanian
Surfer boy how come there's so many
Koreans in Georgia
third largest K Town in the United
States am I right how'd you know that
dude just throwing stats out here number
is that before or after he went there
cuz he added in the per capita he
changed before he went there don't fact
check me but it's a very Siz is it
Atlanta Georgia no no the well
technically the K Town in Georgia is
duut but dut whack duth is whack maretta
till I
die
you heard it here first say Ito [__] it
dud [__] buried it why is the LA though
well duth kids are kind of like the [__]
boys like kind of like well cuz like all
the bars and karaoke like so it's just
very easy to drink are they the toxic
Koreans that girls talk about in Tik Tok
interviews I guess so maretta is a bit
more wholesome nice I think it breeds
better gentleman that's like Anthony Lee
I'm not wholesome I'm [__] hard no
that didn't work [__] can I ask can I
ask why why does your ex have stinky
ears yeah wait by the way how did yeah
what is that about oh so I my girlfriend
uh shout outs to Gina when I was in high
school shout out shout you're out damn
you're putting a name to the ear shout
out Gina Kim if you're out there I
remember like why every time she took a
shower and then we would be like
snuggling I'm like damn your ears so
stink I didn't say that but in my mind I
why you ear she didn't clean her ears
how about the head she had nice head
smell she was using Herbal Essence you
know that was the thing that was the
thing so did you go smell her hair and
you're like oh and then you went down to
your ear and you're
like whoa what's
happening what about you you ever had
any stinky girlfriends no thankfully no
okay cool Asians and Koreans in
general good great hygiene especially
Koreans I think yeah they got the face
care everything but I would say the only
thing would be the garlic
breath once in a while it just hits you
breath it just hits you man I mean I do
it too but then other than that pristine
so good don't fact check me on this
either but apparently Koreans are the
least smelly people on the planet really
I bet that's true body OD wise I put
money on that body who's the most smelly
people on the plan genetic out of Asians
do you think Asian we all have a
thought there's like a the the the
there's a genetic reason for East Asian
actually we lack yeah there's like a
thing the thing yeah or we have onion
smell hyene I think that is no there was
a yeah I read it it was the the same um
Gene that gives us the what kind of ear
wax you have dry it's the same thing
that gives us the like no body odor like
a wolf you know wolves don't have body
odor so that other oh it's like a it's
like a predator thing wow know wolves
don't have BL don't they don't need
deodorant but the reason why they don't
have Bo is so
that that just went over our heads what
because said wolves don't need they
don't need de so the pre never even know
they walk by and they could be an elite
Predator oh it's like you think all
predators are don't smell or what I
didn't smell l so wolves don't smell the
way that dogs can smell no you could wet
that [__] hey take that and then
if you smell that won't be a smelly
that's crazy dog be smelling I think
East Asians generally don't smell but
but when it's rainy I I smelled a stinky
ass Japanese man on the train I was like
[__] you [__] what kind of smell is
that it's rain activated that's the
cigarett probably that's the cigarettes
and what smell would you say it is like
Nat really like [__] fermented
soybean and and sweat man that
[__] smelled like toe stink toe
you think you was just eating a bunch of
not though yeah I almost [__] them up
I was like what's up stinky Yoshi so mad
at some you want to [__] them up that's
a violent response
it's like how could you step on a train
like this I fell asleep at the library
and when I woke up I woke up at a for
this motherfucker's feet stink so bad
he's Chinese stinky ass Chinese man guy
now and his his feet was on the table
with oh that's Chinese yeah yeah with
with a holy sock just [__] swiss
cheese
sock [__] reading a newspaper I'm
like who the [__] reads a newspaper
these days and I looked at him I was
like what the [__] in library how dare
he yeah yeah with the stank foot and it
woke it was stank so bad it woke me up
dude remember those East LA [__]
chairs at the library they were like
nice lazy boys oh my God sleep so
good they haven't changed this term so
you might know but you know athletes
foot in Chinese it's Hong Kong feet waa
no way that's derogatory so imagine like
even in man like in mainland China yeah
everyone just calls it Hong Kong Hong
Kong Fe you know in this like woke
generation you probably can't categorize
a disease with a certain people like oh
you just got Filipino breath bro you
don't have hosis you got
Filipino so it's like they don't even
call it athletes but they call it Hong
Kong feet wow Hong like but that's you
think a doctor be like oh you got a Hong
Kong feet my friend yeah they put it on
the you know you know they call
dreadlocks dirty dirty braids who call
it that Chinese in Chinese dirty braid
it's like literally translated to dirty
but it's not tied to ethnicity or like a
skin tone at the same time an ethnicity
ties themselves to it so they feel oh
you know little derogatory what's worse
then to call it dirty braids or like
Africa hair yeah the second one sounds
way worse cuz like when you put a region
that sounds worse I think it's worse
when it's regional yeah but some people
have some some dudes have good smelling
dreads but then some guys have
or if if it has like a ring to it I
think that's when it's worse white dudes
that they do this [__] their hair for
sure smells when it has a ring like when
it's when it sounds cool that's the
absolute worst if they called it Congo
cap worse yeah yeah that sounds bad no
it's called a Kangle it's different
Kangle hat so back to June now let's
talk about June dude did you get into
acting because of like the scene in
Atlanta and stuff um has a big Hollywood
scene there huh it's Atlanta scene it's
a big production scene it's cuz it's
cheap he like Hong Kong feet out
there we got a we got a case of those
yeah Filipino Beth's
bad hey we call it Pinoy
Breeze Pino Breeze that's
diplomatic how Filipino to make
everything cool sounding dude that was
quick it sounds like a Glade flavor y
let me smell your beer real quick F so
swag at but Atlanta has a good uh big
production so it's everything's cheap
to shoot there but then all the talent
is still getting cast here the only
things the only like roles that are
getting cast in Georgia are still kind
of the more minor roles but the main all
La cuz they're not shooting Walking Dead
anymore right in stranger things Walking
Dead was in Marvel see so do they do
they have like big studios you know we
drive through Burbank and stuff do they
have like big studios like that out
there too oh cool but all the casting is
just mainly done here and then everyone
flies there for they all Outsource a
boring question that maybe you know the
answer to Is there like different like
taxes in Georgia as well where
production is like that much they get
better tax breaks yeah Louisiana Georgia
Vancouver a lot of people got B yeah
anything's got to be better than here so
I'm wondering why like a bunch of like
production doesn't like move over there
what's number one New York Vegas shut
the [__] up it's coming up dude shout
outs to Mark Wahlberg you got his ear
smell good no smelly ear he is trying to
uh produce a Hollywood in Vegas
Hollywood 2.0 I have a question for you
do you see a difference at all between
the Koreans in Georgia and in K toown
like La yeah oh yeah how Southern
Hospitality that's the big difference
it's just it's
ingrained disc to the Koreans out here
huh I like that southern hos hospitality
is pretty sick though it's tight yeah
Southern Hospitality does transcend
every race yeah you just like can't beat
it even when we like get brought out by
like the schools like doesn't if like
Vietnamese and the bay or Texas or North
Carolina when they bring you out it's
just a different type of like warmth
yeah yeah they're sweet like sweet tea
oh the sweet tea in Georgia you have to
try it it's like you instant diabetes
the McDonald's sweet teas is so
guaranteed guaranteed but oh you got to
try it oh that's true the sweet tea here
in McDonald's wasn't the same it's not
that sweet it's like more like unsweet I
don't know is it are there like rules to
Southern Hospitality like Unwritten
rules yeah um like somebody's got shot
on your front por you got to bring him
in and [__] save them type [__] damn
it dude get get the bandages godam I
know you know what I mean is that common
one thing I will say is like
stuff old timey rulle Korean version of
southern hospitality is it does it
differ at all when keep his shoes on
Kore keep bit that's keep give side
dishes with
everything I mean I don't know if
there's a difference with the
Koreans I don't know I think it's just
kind of ingrained where like people
don't make as much eyee contact or small
talk
here um I cuz you don't know if they're
going to bite you or not exactly that's
true that's valid he can't tell I I was
dating a girl that she's never been to
like America and I took her to Georgia
and then we were just driving around
town and I parked in a spot and then the
guy was outside waiting for his door
Dash and then he I like we got out the
car we're walking away he's like oh hey
uh I just saw someone get a ticket 15
minutes ago I was like okay cool and I
got in and then she was like tripped up
about that I was like wait why she's
like do you know that guy I like nah and
so she thought that was like like
strange wow but that is just like a
stranger technically it is strange yeah
cuz like Southern Hospitality um here or
not just here but people that don't know
only equated to like opening the door
yes sir yes ma'am but it's like deep for
like example when a guy's on a date one
thing I tell guys is would thing I tell
ladies is focus Less on if he pulls a
chair out for you but focus more on
where he chooses to sit meaning like I
think that's Southern Hospitality a man
that kind of sits where he can face on
top of the table exactly kind of like
you know what I
mean so he's like kind of taking charge
of so like I think it's just like these
tiny little things I mean the sidewalk
thing that everyone now knows but it's
just these jacket on the puddle jacket
on the so southern hospitality means you
don't believe in equality
huh here's
women actually no under the table I
can't
even but Koreans are still women versus
Korean here's women here's Koreans
that's a good scale I like that scale I
what I do like about it is like when you
grow up in California you have this
stereotype about like Southerners being
racist Hicks and uneducated and mean and
whatever but you go out there that's cuz
California is stupid stupid is dumb dude
the kindest people on Earth and you're
just like this is what they mean like
you really don't get it until you go
there and then you go there and you're
like Texas is awesome the Carolinas is
awesome the south is cool like it's like
all of that area is like oh yeah I mean
like maybe there are like Hicks and
racists and but they treat me better
than the [__] white people here in
California so like straight up dude like
I don't know i' rather around a redneck
than a liberal snob like [__] I get
treated way better by these folks one
thing I do respect about like the south
is you might not agree with them and
they might not agree with you they're
very strong on their morals and beliefs
but there's something respectable about
that even as a man you're like but then
they're usually kind enough where
they're like this is what I think but I
don't yeah they don't expect you to
they're not imposing on your belief one
thing I've noticed about La this is tur
into turning into like a la just like sh
I like I like absolutely valid you're
allowed as an Angelino born and raised
all of us are local we're not
transplants here but one thing I will
say is but I will die ATO you know what
I'm saying yeah that's fair you should
as you should maybe I don't know yeah
you'll probably die here
actually statistically no go ahead go
[__] on La La will la will believe in
anything but
religion what do you mean that it's true
it's true with the LA hat on yeah yeah
like what do you you mean by
that I it's
just everything is a religion plants
yeah you're right oh like astrology
crystals Yoga
Yoga a health like vegan veganism I feel
like Christians in La kind of feel like
oh we got to be secret I feel like being
Christian in 2024 is Extreme yeah that's
the radical behavior that is like right
now that's extremist yeah you're right
that's very true wow yeah no that's
that's a good take cuz in Hawaii I'm
constantly invited to churches like
people openly just be like oh you should
come to my church whatever I just met
you fool that shit's crazy that's like
sleeping on the first date in La no one
would do that like it's rare like people
don't [__] meet you the first day and
go come to my [__] synagogue come to
my church come to my MOS they don't do
that [__] you got to like you got to
date and then they go hey what are you
doing Sunday yeah you know and then you
[__] ask to [__] you know like it's
and then you ask to [__] yeah religion
got replaced by f45 in Soul cycle yo
shout out to
f45 yeah I think I think it's like a
it's a more like oh I don't know you
know if I should say this to them but
that's actually normal like in other
parts of the country is just come to
church with us I think La needs a little
more God you know what I mean I think it
needs to lower anxiety I think there's
so much tension and anxiety in the air
people are like I don't want to I don't
want to inconvenience you I don't want
to talk you I don't know what the [__]
you're dealing with you're probably deal
with some crazy [__] so am I so let's
just so there's all this weird distance
so it just feels like cuz when you go to
the South it doesn't feel like I got to
keep all my [__] to myself oh dude nice
pair of shoes oh cool that's what I love
I love that there just like Humanity
right away versus like La everyone's
like oh I'm [__] late 30 minutes and
I [__] I'm blid on my bills no one
talk to me God damn man you're going to
invite me to your church [__]
you it's like it just feels like like
[__] rubs off on you too it's like just
like that girl it's like when you do
face that Hospitality somewhere else
you're like thrown off right it's not
like a normal like it's like oh yeah
this is what it should be like at first
you're like whoa uh yeah I guess we'll
talk right now like a Uber or lift
driver that picks you up in another
airport or something like that they're
like super like super nice but they're
asking everything personal but usually
in La you [__] like put on your
airpods or some [__] and you sit for
like 45 minutes in traffic don't talk
and if someone tries to talk to you
you're like what the [__] do you want
for what what's [__] angle well you
know why though you trying to get a tip
I don't want to read a script dude I
have an agent all right you know why I
don't want to do herb life all right
it's I am an agent we probably did open
up and got burnt for it that's a big
city thing there's a lot of cons here
there's a lot of crazy people here lot
of traffic moving there's a lot of [__]
going on here and you there's like
consequences for your kindness and I
think that's what happens a lot where
people close up or they get annoyed
really quick and then sometimes you ride
the Metro station La and then you get
lice there's a lice Outbreak on the
[__] Metro station that's the next
thing that happens yeah isn't that crazy
oh yeah what's your favorite thing about
it is like the light yeah ticks you like
The
Tick let me let me say this in front of
the camera um I think La does enough
dreaming for the rest of the country wow
that's a really cool statement that's
that's really romantic that's pretty
deep though yeah I think yeah la is the
beacon of like imagination creativity
like foresight like where are we going
to take culture we going to push the
boundaries and then I think everyone
goes say what you want about La but
that's true I think a lot of those
people are the ones that are fearful of
chasing their dreams hey you know I'm
proud of be in La dude the the other
cities and states they're they're
they're scared of chasing their dreams
yeah like the people that are like just
just purely [__] on LA yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah I think yeah I think there's a
little bit of that um I think just the N
uh nature of La is the first year or two
you're like this is the worst city in
the world and then something happens
you're like it happens in year 40 kind
of nice LA's kind of nice it's like okay
and so that that kind of happened to me
and um I love La that's I think it's
funny for me because I grew up here so I
it's almost like you have to talk [__]
about it cuz it's funny but true but
there's something that brings me back
consistently I mean you're still here
and I think you're right it's it's not
our lease
yeah we have a lease not this that's a
small thing yeah five commitment I
think it might be also big city right
but but the thing is I've now worked in
different cities met with different
people in different cities and how they
operate is completely different it's
much slower you have less motivated
people or or driven people and dreamy
people right so like you can get a group
together and we're like all right we're
going to execute this thing in La you
have people that get it and they'll be
like all right tomorrow it's done and
we're just going Bam Bam Bam like I'm
not saying people have bad work ethics I
don't want to be confused with that yeah
at ji Hawaii no it's just a
different level of speed and pace and
mentality and New York Yorkers are
probably 10 times what La is without the
creativity so I think it's like out here
you have Tech entertainment um a lot I
mean entrepreneurs are everywhere but
the types here it's like you have way
more so you have like maybe thousands of
people that you can Network and play
with to assemble and get a game going
versus other cities maybe your circle's
a 100 so it's like you have less options
to kind of get together and it might be
even more competitive where you can't
like work in a way where it's
collaborative because everyone has their
section whereas in La there's like it's
almost Limitless where it's like I don't
really like this group right here and we
can compete but I can find this other
group here that meshes well with my
personality I think that's the biggest
thing I've noticed yeah bigger
Market yeah it's like limit yeah it
really feels endless here whereas other
places you can see the limitations
you're just like oh there's only one
industry [__] on New York a little bit
more there's like one theater yeah get
them real mad I have some New York stuff
too yeah what you got are we just
[__] on all the cities let's just go
down the list too expensive everyone
getting priced out
dude I don't know [__] about New York I
love New York too I don't know anything
but the funniest thing on it I love it
it's love hate with everything right I
think the funniest thing to me is I
think New Yorkers when they go outside
everyone's like oh wow you're from New
York when they come to La we're like so
you know what New York people very
stylish so folks are very stylish they
got more weather so they got more
options to like we're supposed to talk
[__] about New York Tupac versus bro Q
me Q me very
stylish but dude they're going to the
[__] grocery store bro like just
relax a little bit just a little bit
just there's the shade yeah you're going
You're Buck your erand dude you buying
milk in crocodile boots they crazy Bro
[__]
du
[Music]
what